¿Recordáis el Manifiesto Comunista y su
famoso comienzo de "un fantasma recorre
Europa"?
Pues bien, a diferencia de lo que
planteaban Marx y Engels, en nuestros días
no es el fantasma del comunismo el que
se cierne sobre Europa sino el de la
xenofobia y la extrema derecha. Hace 70
años el racismo y el nacionalismo
redujeron Europa a cenizas, hoy algunas de
estas ideas vuelven a estar de moda. Pero,
puede que os preguntéis ¿Quiénes son
realmente estos partidos de extrema
derecha? ¿Que fuerza tienen? ¿Qué es lo que
quieren? En este vídeo hablamos de la
nueva derecha que ha brotado en el viejo
continente.
Vamos a ello.
Francia, Holanda, Dinamarca, Alemania...
La extrema derecha está creciendo como
la espuma,
a lo largo y ancho de toda Europa.
Casi podemos decir que España y
Portugal son las únicas excepciones a
esta ola de fanatismo y radicalidad.
Aunque... cuidado con los términos porque
tal y como nos contó Fonseca en un
pasado vídeo, cada vez resulta más
difícil determinar dónde queda la
derecha y donde la izquierda
Como sabéis, amigos de VisualPolitik, en
los últimos años el debate político
ha cambiado. Hemos pasado de escoger
entre más lo menos intervención, a
decidir entre globalización sí o
globalización no. Por eso no es extraño
que estos partidos de extrema derecha
recojan muchas posturas tradicionales de
la izquierda, como el proteccionismo, la
estatalización de sectores económicos
o más planes de bienestar.
Es curioso, pero por ello la extrema derecha
está quitándole votos sobre todo a los
partidos de izquierdas. Y... cuidado, porque
en 2017
hay varias elecciones importantes:
Francia, Holanda, Finlandia y como
ocurrió en las de diciembre de 2016 en
Austria
estos partidos van a tener mucho
protagonismo e influencia.
- "Dicen que soy un lobo con piel de
cordero, pues bien se equivocan no lo soy
no tengo ningún tipo de piel".  Y desde
luego la victoria del Trump les ha dado
energía, mucha energía.
En VisualPolitik
prestaremos mucha atención a estos
procesos y las analizaremos uno a uno pero hoy
vamos a ver una radiografía de esta
nueva extrema derecha.
Pero, ¿qué piensan estos
partidos? ¿Qué persiguen? ¿Qué les une?
Pues aunque no podamos decir que sean todos
idénticos sí que tienen algunas
características comunes: en primer lugar,
son muy nacionalistas y recelosos de la
soberanía nacional.
Por ello defienden, según los casos, o
abandonar la Unión Europea o transformarla, acabando con el proyecto comunitario
de integración política. Es decir,
quieren limitar la unión a un acuerdo
estrictamente económico. Ya os podéis
imaginar, amigos, que con el Brexit
lanzaron fuegos artificiales.
- " No es Europa la que ha muerto es la
Unión Europea la que se tambalea".
Por otro lado, y con la excepción del UKIP
y del Partido de la Libertad de Holandam
estos partidos defienden el
proteccionismo y que sea el estado el
que marque el rumbo económico.
Vamos, que de liberales no tienen nada.
Por último, el punto tal vez más
importante.
Consideran las diferencias culturales y
la inmigración como una amenaza para la
identidad nacional.
- "Europa debería cumplir con sus valores
judeocristianos, esos valores deberían
ser preservados y protegidos para las
próximas generaciones". Y no sólo eso,
para estos partidos la inmigración
causa también inseguridad, pérdida de
puestos de trabajo y muchísimos coste
para el estado. Por ello al hablar de
inmigración es muy habitual que estos
partidos utilicen  de forma peyorativa
el término "invasión", aunque, por
supuesto, ésta no existe en absoluto.
Fijaros, el número de inmigrantes en toda
la Unión Europea es de aproximadamente
34 millones de personas. Pueden parecer
muchas pero representan menos del
siete por ciento de la población,
un porcentaje muy inferior al de países
como Australia, Nueva Zelanda o Canadá. Bueno, ¡menos de la mitad!
Aunque, claro,  los datos no siempre cuentan.
Zonas como Sajonia en Alemania, donde
apenas hay inmigrantes, son grandes
caladeros de votos para este tipo de
partidos de extrema derecha, precisamente
por el miedo a la inmigración, o sea el
miedo a lo desconocido. Es verdad
en algunos casos hay problemas graves de
integración, como ocurre, por ejemplo, con
la población musulmana que por sí
mismo supone otra de las grandes bazas
para estos partidos.
- "Mi pregunta es ¿queréis en esta ciudad
y en Holanda más o menos marroquíes?
dijo en la Haya.
Pero sería muy
injusto generalizar y banalizar un
problema tan complejo.
Por cierto, tal vez pueda sorprenderos
pero hoy hay menos terrorismo en Europa
que en las décadas de los 70, los 80 y los
90.
No lo digo para obviar el problema que
hoy sufrimos, ni muchísimo menos, pero
frente a lo que podamos sentir esta es
la realidad.
En cualquier caso, amigos, combatir el
odio con políticas que surgen desde el
propio odio no suele traer buenos
resultados. Y, personalmente, no creo que
aislarse del mundo sea la mejor
solución, ni siquiera una solución.
Bien, vistas sus características
comunes es posible que os estáis
preguntando ¿pero quiénes son estos
partidos? Así que, veamos caso por caso
los partidos de extrema derecha que más
influencia política están ganando en
Europa.
El Partido por la Libertad de Geert Wilders
es ya el primero en intención de voto, y no es
que sus políticas sean precisamente
moderadas.
Este partido se presenta ante el
público con la misión ojo, de des-islamizar
Holanda y ¿cómo lo quiere lograr?
Pues cerrando todas las mezquitas,
prohibiendo el Corán, prohibiendo el velo
islámico y cerrando las fronteras a cal
y canto a todas las personas musulmanas.
Su otra propuesta estrella, como no,
abandonar la Unión Europea para
recobrar la soberanía nacional.
- "La Unión Europea se ha quedado con la
soberanía de Holanda, quienes están a cargo ahora
son los comisarios, a quien no conoce
nadie en Holanda; y peor, a quienes nadie
ha elegido".
El Frente Nacional es, sin lugar a dudas,
el decano de los partidos de extrema
derecha en Europa. Tiene su origen en la
época de de Gaulle y la independencia
de Argelia en 1962, que provocó un
cabreo monumental en gran parte de la
población francesa.
De hecho, para luchar contra la
independencia de Argelia algunos altos
mandos militares y políticos formaron lo
que se conoció como la "Organización
del Ejército Secreto", un grupo
terrorista que, además de actuar en
Argelia y en Francia, trato, incluso,
de acabar con la vida del propio general
de Gaulle.
- "El grupo había realizado en sólo un
año de vida más de 700 acciones
armadas y había convertido a de
Gaulle en su principal objetivo".
Pues bien, es de esos mimbres de donde
surge el Frente Nacional, un partido de
corte xenófobo y ultranacionalista
Y ¿Qué es lo que quiere? Bueno, creo que
prácticamente lo podéis adivinar:
luchar contra la inmigración, abandonar
el euro,
salirse de la Unión Europea y apostar
por políticas proteccionistas.
Sí amigos, de hecho, la política económica que
proponen es bastante de izquierdas,
incluso quiere subir los impuestos ¡en
Francia, que ya es uno de los países con
más impuestos del mundo!
Claro que, a la vista de los
acontecimientos, con todo los atentados
que han sacudido a Francia últimamente
no nos puede extrañar que este partido
dirigido por Marine Le Pen esté
luchando por ser la primera fuerza
política del país ¡Casi nada!
En diciembre de 2016 el FPO, liderado
por Norbert Hofer
bajo el lema "Austria y los austriacos
primero" se quedó a cinco puntos de
ganar las presidenciales y convertirse,
atentos, en el primer país europeo
gobernado por la extrema derecha desde
1945.
Hofer y el FPO repiten el patrón típico.
Prometen cuidar del
estado del bienestar,
evitando que los inmigrantes puedan
acceder a él; apuesta por fronteras
cerradas; defiende la familia tradicional
y se declara euroescéptico.
No defienden
abandonar de entrada la Unión Europea
pero si quieren que ésta abandone su
carácter político; y en cualquier caso
apuestan por celebrar un referéndum
sobre la pertenencia en la misma para que
sea el propio pueblo austriaco el que
decida si seguir o marcharse.
Su influencia ya se nota en Austria: el 77
por ciento de los encuestados afirman
tener una mala imagen sobre los
refugiados.
El caldo de cultivo que generan estos
partidos tiene consecuencias.
"La Alternativa para Alemania" es un partido
político euroescéptico creado hace muy
poco, en 2013.
Este es un partido un tanto diferente
porque aunque entre sus filas hay
verdaderos radicales
su origen está más ligado a la crisis,
a las dudas hacia el euro y al recelo
con los países del sur de Europa.
Eso sí, no perdieron la oportunidad de
aprovechar la crisis de los refugiados
para sacar rédito político.
Ahí se produjo el salto al populismo,
que a decir verdad, de momento les está
funcionando muy bien.
Con la victoria del Brexit han sido los
grandes triunfadores.
Aunque la verdad es que el UKIP es un
partido bastante peculiar. Su base tiende
a ser más liberal que proteccionista y
en buena medida se declaran herederos
políticos de Margaret Thatcher.
Su obsesión es, y ha sido, la Unión Europea.
Pero, claro, tampoco han dudado en tirar
de discurso antiinmigración para ganar
adeptos.
Y aunque estos son los más
destacados,
no son ni mucho menos los únicos.
Por ejemplo, en Dinamarca el Partido Popular
Danés fue el segundo partido más
votado; en el gobierno finés están los
Verdaderos Finlandeses que tienen ideas
similares a las que hemos visto en el
vídeo; y los demócratas de Suecia, la
derecha radical sueca, tienen aún mucho
recorrido por delante.
Y respecto a Europa del Este y Europa
Central...
bueno, casi que mejor lo dejamos para
otro vídeo.
Bueno, ¿Cuál es tu opinión?
¿Son estos partidos una amenaza?
¿Cómo se puede derrotar su discurso?
Esperamos vuestros respuestas.Si os ha gustado
el vídeo, dadle a like, y por cierto si
queréis ver qué ocurre en un país sin
inmigración, no os perdáis el caso de Japón,
lo podéis ver haciendo clic aquí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima, amigos.